my father grew up in the deep south in
the 1940s and 50s at a time when schools
were still segregated and the promise of
going to college was less a promise and
more like a game of roulette and so for
many like him the only real choices they
had were to stay in their hometown
going to the military
or to attempt to go to college
well my father served 20 years proudly
and honorably in the united states air
force
the barriers to college were just too
high
when he retired from the military he did
go back to college and using his gi bill
and studying at night for almost six
years
he graduated one year
before i was graduating from college
i remember going to his commencement
and watching him walk across the stage
in my eyes just just filled with tears
and i actually i'm not sure that i saw
him get his diploma because i was crying
like a baby
you know around the world less than
seven percent of people own a bachelor's
degree
but there are many
who would like to go to university
but for them much like my father
the barriers to getting into and
graduating from college
are just too high
it simply costs too much
and that cost
is often the price of tuition
in the united states
a four-year bachelor's degree can cost
in excess of 100 000
and that price point continues to
escalate
and this is true in other parts of the
world but sometimes the cost is high
because there's no university nearby to
study on or
offline or because the academic hurdles
are so high
that university is only afforded to the
privileged few
we as institutions of higher education
we build walls around ourselves and
expect students to find their ways over
but it shouldn't be
what i care most about and what i have
devoted my entire career to as an
educator and now as an administrator at
one of the largest universities in the
united states
is seeing more people traditional
college age as well as working adults
getting into and graduating from college
but if we are to do this
institutions are going to have to
redesign themselves to reach out and
reach for more students
versus students trying to reach the
institutions
over those walls
and if we are going to do that
we have to dramatically drive down the
cost of higher education
and the way to do it is to rethink and
reimagine
in these three ways
we have to rethink time
place
and how we teach
so the first is time time goes hand in
hand with cost
and this is how it typically goes
college courses and degrees are
typically assessed based on credit hours
and each credit
cost
money so therefore in this scenario
time
therefore
cost is fixed
and learning
is variable
this really makes it problematic to
drive down cost
and it particularly becomes problematic
if you're trying to balance school
work
and other family obligations as well as
other obligations and responsibilities
but if we were to flip that scenario
and therefore make learning
the constant
and time variable
then we break the tyranny of time
i mean really isn't that what school is
about it's about learning and gaining
mastery
versus logging in a particular number of
hours
so
what could we do
we should make
and give academic credit for life
experiences
why sit through an entire business
management course for a semester
when you can have a university evaluator
assess you based on your experience
so this is what this would look like
let's take a student
brandeis
brandes is an automotive technician at a
car service center
now let's take three of the
certifications that she received and is
required for her to do her work
uh electrical systems
uh manual drivetrain and axles and
engine performance
now you take those and you couple with
the fact that brandis is actually
managing
a team of technicians on the floor
you assess all of that
and she finds out that she's just a few
credits shy of a college degree a degree
in automotive engineering or engineering
management
and then on top of that
during that assessment
she finds out that she has a pathway to
receive the remainder of those credits
for her degree
in less than five months
a few of us are doing this
but here's what i hope for
my hope
is that time
becomes
even
more variable
so let's build a global skills bank much
like a financial bank
but in this case
skills and experiences are the currency
so if you take an evening course in
accounting
deposit that
into your bank
if you do a summer internship at a
marketing firm deposit that
into your bank
if we're able to do this
and do this at scale
we could dramatically decrease the time
to complete a degree
therefore drive down cost
second
place
we have to completely re-envision and
re-imagine how we think and we see place
we know that physical college campuses
are expensive to maintain
and we have to understand that we should
look at learning options in a variety of
different ways
but there's also another cost that we
need to lower
and it's the cost of belonging
whether it's because there's not a
learning institute university nearby for
you to learn be it on or offline
or because there are emotional or
cultural walls
that disconnect the learner from that
learning location
cameron as a student
should be able to take classes in a
community center or in his church
he should be able to seek career
advising and support from local business
owners and businesses
we should be able to take his work and
his volunteer experiences and turn those
into credits all in a community that he
trusts
and then therefore we are making that
community a thriving
vital part of a learning ecosystem for
him
and for many others
if we can do this
this means that we absolutely have to
believe that learning can take place
anywhere
and if we do
then we decrease the cost
of place
finally
teaching what about teaching
well teaching is at the heart of
learning
teaching is the inspiration and the
connection it is the spark that connects
the learner
to the information
so there's nothing that we want to do to
mess with that magic
but we do know that teaching is one of
the higher cost of education
so what do we do
we should take the most inspirational
and engaging
teachers
and all that teaching charm that comes
with it
and make bigger classrooms for them
scaling
and expanding their reach
so most classes are 20 to 30 students or
in some cases a couple of hundred
but in online
you can reach thousands all around the
world
we currently have a course called human
relations in administration it's a
foundational course for all
undergraduate business majors
this course has upwards of three
thousand students
from all over the world
the us
canada germany india and the list just
goes on and on
we also have classes that are upwards of
5000 and we aspire to scale even more
we want it so that
wherever you have an internet connection
you can put a virtual butt in a sea
now
there are folks who are skeptical about
online particularly large online
classrooms and they posit in that
smaller classrooms are better
but i would argue what smaller
classrooms are really providing
is personalization
and so with personalization
this is what i want to see
i want to see a student regardless of
where they are regardless of their
location to have a single source be it
their mobile phone or their laptop where
they have access to instruction in real
time
or in their time
i want a faculty member
to be able to
anticipate a particular need for a
student
outreach to that student
provide a connection for that student
with a pre-packaged
academic toolkit that was prepared by a
virtual or automated resource or service
and provide that human intervention for
that student
just at the right time
that's what chat bots and predictive
analytics in ai can provide a university
insights into when is it the right time
to provide that human intervention that
helps that student to become unstuck
and to provide that personal support
the student may need
some of us are doing this
but if we can really do this and do this
at scale
we are solving the problem by building
faculty to do the thing that they are
best at
and to do that inspiration at scale
and at the same time
we are helping to drive down the cost of
higher education by still providing the
personal support at the time that it's
needed
so i began this talk talking about my
father
there's a lot that has changed about
higher education over this period of
time and there are things that have not
changed
we as institutions
still find ourselves being exclusive and
expensive
keeping students on the wrong side of
that wall
instead of thousands of autonomous
universities
this is what i would like to see happen
i would like to see universities
companies and governments invest deeply
in a higher education super highway
that allows for the fluidity and the
transferability of experiences from
place to place
from workplace to the classroom
beyond borders
and beyond boundaries
and in this case
skills and competencies become the
currency for a global workforce
and if we're able to do this
i invite you
to a graduation
where we will have seen millions
and possibly billions of students walk
across that stage
thank you
[Applause]